qui n'a pas vu bouquet dans la barre n'a
jamais vu la barre grâce à intel
serviteur molière et lumineux sont
incomparables peinture de l'âme humaine
nous est vendu dans ce après leur
première il est austère il est tellement
tost est requis dans du rigolo j'ai dit
que la peste soit de la parité était
avaricieux que tu veux tu parles et
d'habitués qui s'en occupe c'est la
marque des lilas et des pièges de la
beauté des personnages de molière c'est
que ils peuvent avoir tous les vices du
monde et toutes les caractéristiques de
la méchanceté
il résonne en nous avec humanité
je vais me marier l'hôtel vous plaît
mais moi ma petite amie
je veux que le nouveau briller s'il vous
plaît lampard dans mon père je vous
demande pardon bâti est enfin c'est les
contradictions qui dans molière sont les
plus importantes
n'est ce pas il nous il nous fait voir
ce personnage tout à coup aussi fragile
aussi débile que jeunes enfants et puis
tout à coup il nous le montre comme un
vieillard ference et et tyrannique
les arrêts morizet ou qui arrivent sur
les tons vert et le froid qui arrive et
nous on pointe du van zon plus tendre
europe à l'heure et la personne ne
connaît avec deux fautes pas dans vos
menaces de bagua moi du tout de grâce
c'est qu'on sait des nouvelles de mon
voleur je supplie que normandie mais tel
point qu'à celle a parmi vous il me
regarde tous
il se met à rire vous verrez qu'ils sont
pas sans doute encore que l'on m'a fait
alors vecteur les commentaires des
archers d'être égaux des juges kg des
potences et des bourreaux je veux bien
prendre tout le monde et si je me
retrouve mon argent je ne prendrai ma
mère pour elle